I love the fact that women generally in
terms of preference to men I respect the
fact though that it's not bias I respect
the fact that it's fair game and what I
mean by that is
is that a guy who feels like he always
gets the short end of the stick never
goes his way
on one hand he might develop a hate a
resentment for women or women in my
enemy we've all heard many talk like
that yeah but then there are some men
who go do you know what
if I took a bit better care of myself
or improved my social standing improve
my income like women are not so biased
that like just because I never used to
have them things when I become that
they're not going to hold it against me
that I never used to have that I'm now
going to get treated as a man who has
those things yeah do you understand what
I'm saying those men become players
though because
those men reach a level you you work on
yourself but then you look at these
women you realize these women are basic
as hell bro I was chasing I was chasing
women he dropped out of school just
because she had a nice ass asking me to
take her out to the restaurants I
realized yo this woman is basic so what
I'll do is I'll date four or five of
them yeah and I'll entertain them and
when they each of them has their issue
I'll just go on a hinge get a few more
matches and replace her like that
I was gonna say before when you said
these girls have these standards and
then you surprised who they end up with
yeah that's not that's not by mistake
can I ask a question about Wi-Fi
material is it a gents so for example
those that you like the 25 year old as
you mentioned or that's the the standard
if that 25 year old is aesthetically
pleasing and you're looking based on
Aesthetics Etc are you looking at the
core morals and values that will make
her a wife because if she's more
interested in for example the Birkin
than the home and the children because
we're not going to put seven bedrooms in
a Rolex or a handbag so for me it's like
if your focus is you want to look good
and you want to go to fancy restaurants
Etc to me that's not a wife because
she's not thinking about keeping her
home looking after your family Etc
you're looking at us I think I think
older women I think older women value
that stuff more than younger women and
also men are very happy to tick a few
things off of their list
um to get what they want we compromise
yeah yeah we are we are very good at
compromising with the list that we want
and so and the thing is also and the
reason why is because men's list is
isn't that big what's on your list
a woman who you know is going to be a
good mother woman who's know it's going
to cooperate a woman who you know is
gonna get with the quote-unquote program
um
a woman who's friendly a woman who takes
care of herself
intelligence is massive
intelligence if at any point that's the
number one I don't care how cute you are
if if you ever struck me as dumb I won't
tell you but we're never getting far
because I'm not having dumb kids in
2024.
being attuned to reality that's why I
think the dating market sucks right now
because these women are not here like
it's more dangerous for women to level
up in life whilst single way more
dangerous for them than the Magnum when
women say like I'm working on life and
I'm leveling up all these different
components of my life but doing this
with no man involved for the
heterosexual women obviously with no man
involved I think that is dangerous bro
because reason being right because
sorry because
the things that come with said level up
in a female I.E
higher earnings
[Music]
um depop moral understanding of where it
went wrong the last decade
etc etc like that doesn't those things
don't necessarily create a fair enough
balance for simply the age aspect for it
to really be a fair trade-off in the
eyes of most guys I don't feel I feel
like basically if you were with a guy
and you were growing older with him fair
enough your physical stunning
um that whole aspect may come down
but you're leveling up with someone
you're already with so you're not you
don't have the conundrum basically right
of the fact that you've leveled up in
life and you still have this issue where
you still now need to become attractive
to the sort of man that you perceive to
be where you're at you know and and
that's and that's a conundrum I think
that has left a lot of women on their
own Unable to pair with someone yeah
what about if your woman levels up above
you know levels up but goes above you
while you're in the relationship so for
example with myself she lives yeah
that's what happened with me that's why
I was asking because because yeah you go
above them in some way and then you're
then dissatisfied with the balance
honestly like okay so you're a high
earner is that what you said yeah so
would you be okay if you got married to
a guy I know you're dating a girl but I
don't I don't know the girl girl
Dynamics so let's let's talk guy right
would you be comfortable with him
managing the money is your money his not
money
yeah if we're married okay so you
however managing it as in I don't have
any control over it yeah nope but I
wouldn't even if I was a lesser earner
it's that I would still not be
comfortable with that yeah and and see
this is that like why men don't want to
date High earners is because it's it's
they often have a hard time
relinquishing control which is part of
femininity yeah yeah because because for
me like like I do pretty well with this
channel right but I I hope to date a guy
that I can trust with the finances I
don't have to deal with it like that
that's my mindset and I can have this oh
sorry Ramsey guys no just off of what um
D was saying about it's dangerous for
women to be leveling up and doing the
whole I'm working on me
oh sorry I can say from experience
agreed but I would say more that it
makes you because as a woman it makes
you live in your masculine it turns you
masculine right so when you're then
going back into day and you have to
re-learn how to be soft how to be
feminine how to accept somebody to take
control because you've had to look
you've taken control you've gone all
right cool do you know what I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do that be independent
whatever so I definitely agree with that
what happens is it makes the ultimate
toxic being right you have when women
get into their masculine then when they
come back to the feminine they try and
mix up the best parts of both so when
it's convenient they want to be
masculine when it's convenient so
they'll say stuff like I need a man who
earns more than me but I also need
really good sex but I also need him to
get give me the drains once in a while
these kind of ridiculous things where
it's like basically you want to flip
roles when it's convenient same thing
with men when men get feminine and they
start doing this whole emotional stuff
then they start becoming controlling and
toxic in a really weird way same thing
yeah but I wouldn't agree with that in
the the picking and choosing I think
it's more not all but there's probably
women out there that are 100 doing this
we know this but I definitely say with
it's just re-learning how to be soft and
feminine because I think when you've
been so hard in that you don't pick and
choose you your your program to just be
that person all the time well it's not a
choice it's the being it's it's either
it's either your phone yeah it's either
it's either you're feminine or you're
not it's either it's either you have it
in you or you don't no yes you do
because because you're either raised to
be a wife or you weren't
your environment actually respect your
journey the fact that you can actually
have self-reflection 100 introspection
to say you know what I was like this and
it wasn't really working out for me and
you know what and it's changed I respect
100 100 and there's and and it's
interesting in conversations like this
how
how
if I'm speaking for myself personally I
understand it yeah speaking to my own
lived experiences family friends local
environment whatever I understand it
right but I do find it fascinating
sometimes how in conversations like this
women who struggle with being in tune
with their femininity for whatever
reason
it seems to be a notion that is far more
expected to be understood by the fellas
then
women understanding men who may battle
with their masculinity because to some
women the notion of a man who battles
with being a man is crazy
but but it doesn't sound crazy to you
how me as a man would hear I'm dating
this woman who's battling with being
feminine do you know what
um
I kind of I think I'm I think because
I've had moments in my journey where
I've reflected I've understood when I
meet men and I realize they're coming to
me in this energy okay I get it and I'll
be that person if you want to talk or
maybe let me shed light on certain
things that maybe someone said to you
but I I do it's both crazy okay I'm
gonna Read Super chats because I I feel
bad I'm sorry Chad
um you've had some good questions today
um a lot I had complaints last time I
always get complaints about my reading
the super chats that I don't ask the
questions that you guys put in so I was
trying to work on that but now the chat
is saying I don't read all of them look
at I can't you can't have everything
okay so Jose Perez yo Pearl I need you
on fresh and fair I've been impression
fit you're going to be huge in the space
and I recently started watching your
videos you haven't missed the red pill
is strong in you it's funny to hear all
of the accents Dan lady and
I bass r44 damn lady in red I feel for
you guy on your guys on your financial
level won't check you seriously and guys
below you you'll eventually hate because
you wear the pants the lady in red 45
year old 45 gets real lonely grow up red
belongs to the streets 90 free Tope what
up Pearl I have I see the tan wore off
as a sunburn please ask the female panel
how they would
this is a good question I'm going to ask
it how would you keep a man outside of
sex
um mentally and emotionally how
um I would be there for him like what he
really needs like you like I said you
you have to figure out the pattern
person you're with so you work out their
strengths their weaknesses so you figure
out okay how can I be of service to you
how can I help you fulfill your full
potential and can I also answer yeah
outside of sex sex is not the Beyond end
all guys okay all right let me just make
that very very clear it's not it's just
that I spent many years not putting sex
as a priority I know for everything else
you are moonwalking right now
is Michael Jackson
she's sorry take her back yeah she's
sorry
it sounds like you do everything but I'm
selective I don't multiple dates so I
just want to make that very very very
sounds like a disrespecting your guys
dick game this is the remix oh my God
Can't Win It just seems like I can't win
for me outside of sex is mental um
stimulation you have to be intelligent
you have to be able to actually they're
asking what you you give well I'll give
like emotional intelligence and mental
stimulation
okay what do you say
um I would outside of sex obviously I'm
just gonna be the woman for my man
whatever it is that he needs whether
it's like like nurturing caring for him
just being there
you really you realize you realize being
there is like nothing like anyone can be
there
okay so by the way I'm a very good coach
I exist around my mind yeah
what do they think a man wants um
it's a bag of discombobulated nonsense
right right but if you said cook that
would have been a good answer if you ask
men but that's what do they think women
as a woman we can be very structured oh
they want to predictions
for some reason women just like Dee was
saying earlier on men have been
listening to women for so long that we
understand what women actually want yeah
actually women have been listening to
themselves for so long yeah that they
have no clue what men want yes they've
got a clue I don't care about anyone
can I add I think also things like
support for the family so I think that's
it very important for men if a man's a
real man he also respects his mother
respect if he has a father his family so
also being a part of his extended family
I know a lot of women who may become
wives or partners and they're there just
for the man but what about when his mom
needs something or needs taken to an
appointment or you know nieces and
nephews showing that you've got more to
give than just it's not just me chilling
around my man watching what he's doing
is is contributing actively towards his
tribe and his family unit to show that
you've placed yourself correctly in that
and you have something to offer Beyond
just your body that benefits his wider
Community that's what what else what
else so on top of that I would say
Obviously for me it is it is things like
keeping the home respecting him being
able to show that when you're with him
that you're um a trophy in the sense of
not just physically but a trophy in the
sense of you conduct yourself properly
you're a respectable individual you have
the correct values that they keep if
you're me I'm quite spiritual so if
there's spiritual and mental attributes
for that sometimes men are not always
strong so sometimes men go through
difficult times okay okay
seriously I want to hear from the guys
is there anything is there anything
no no I wanna I wanna hear from the guys
is there anything they said that would
be of value
anything anything what do you guys want
from a girl I said earlier on okay
remember I said someone who's a good
mother right someone who's uh
someone who's intelligent like my man
said over here right someone who you
know who's gonna get with your program
uh if our list is not very all of that
what I want to be submissive
so listen to me so what I want is um
someone who's
at least as intelligent as I am minimum
right
um someone who's physically fit and
takes care of the health I've dated
people who are 25 are like oh I'm
getting wet yeah you're way too early
for that I'm out you know you're
literally the peak of your life and
you're gay you're having weight troubles
already that's a world in the making and
third I want someone who's just like um
adaptable who like has values values are
big like I know a lot of women who do
their best to get it past me that like
they don't have to say the right things
but I can see whether you really value
loyalty loyalty
um whether you're considerate whether
you think about other people and whether
you know how to like let a man be a man
or whether you're going to be in my face
making things difficult without to
tolerate you in the future you sharp and
to the points
what about you
foreign
there needs to be serious pushback in
the whole community of relationship talk
real man forget it like stop saying that
because because who am I to tell you
what constitutes a real woman I'll get
Council on the Internet by tomorrow it's
not saying what a real man is because
you don't
no
and you've got friends who are raising
Sons with no dad around and women are
gonna tell him when he grows up here in
a real man but you ain't telling your
friends today raw you're raising up the
sun with no dad but he's gonna struggle
when he grows up knowing it telling
their friends that but you're quick to
tell men they're not real men push back
what are you looking for in a feminine
personally I'm looking for a woman see I
want a woman erase me who I want a woman
who treats me like I'm the best that she
could have got okay yes that's who
that's who I want still you want to feel
needed yeah like I want to feel I want
because if I don't yeah because and
here's the thing I understand that
a certain
color bar or highly regarded woman what
whatever may not feel that way about me
that's fine I I accept that but I
understand that there's levels I get it
everyone is not the same level but I
also understand that you know I need to
be with a woman who feels that way about
me so if that woman is a two out of ten
to the world cool but that's how she
feels about me and that lets me that
gives me a sense of confidence she makes
me feel like I'm gonna have the kind of
relationship that I want you see we see
forget all this stuff like I want a man
who makes me feel like a 10 but he
actually has to be a 10.
guys will go down and looks to go up in
submissiveness what massively yeah I
don't I don't date nines tensions just
because at that point it's kind of like
um some guys
why should I why should I work so hard
to get a Ferrari when a Volkswagen Golf
does exactly the same same job it's more
reliable this is the difference though
how intelligence Like rules the dating
Community because there's some guys who
are dumb enough to chase these top goals
then they get run they get run for
everything they got and they're crying
I'm like dude because she's just good
looking that's all she's got but on the
flip side the thing is what happens with
that is that women see guys giving those
women attention right and they think
guys want that it's like when guys go to
strip clubs all of the women in strip
clubs look like great well they see the
[ __ ] boys giving those guys attention
and they compete for the fuckboys
yeah but it's like those women in the
strip clubs and those women on Instagram
right you guys are giving attention
women General women see them be like oh
is that what guys want no they just
wanted to like say yes that looks great
but that's not gonna be his wife it's
like I ask guys all the time um BBL or
natural butt and and they and they and
what a lot of guys would say for the
night vvl but for long term I'll take
I'll take now I'll take no butt over a
BBL yeah because that's a wife and
that's for fun Aesthetics is controlling
a lot of if you look at like guys you
see I've watched my brother's go through
Instagram right and that your blood it's
it's all it's programmed in you scroll
you like you scrub fire fire
women don't well not to my knowledge
have a load of guys they follow on
Instagram oh he's buff he's buff so you
see like the biological drivers of sex
driving men if you understand that sex
drives men you understand that that's
just the sex that in the longevity of
that the woman who is the Instagram
model with you know all of these
eyelashes you could fly to join eye on
and nothing else and then that's not
going to be the wife as you said it's a
short-term solution but it because
certain women then allow themselves to
lack that intelligence to see what's
really going on here they stay doing all
of that nonsense for years and years
until they are no longer eligible until
they're a baby mum with multiple baby
fathers I aspire to never be anyone's
baby mother like personally
I'm yeah I'm nearly 29 you know I'm in a
relationship I don't want to be
someone's baby mum and not you know it's
I would aspire to be a wife and you know
this generation everyone wants lots of
things but whether you become a baby mom
or not is dependent on your values of
course I think I think no one says they
do but I can tell who's going to be one
based on the kind of stuff they say
those girls that want to ten and want
this and that one explore sexuality I
don't have money
of women are going to be the first
generation of women
the first generation of grandmas with
bbls
[Music]
no husbands no husbands face tattoos and
we tattooed all over the place like like
this is gonna be we're gonna be the
first generation of grandmothers Mass
picks on Instagram
what are y'all doing what are y'all
doing do you not have families do you
not have families that are gonna see
that and this is just to see them
I had a whole I got a whole platform
right you will not catch me posting ass
pics on Instagram and I can make money
off of that [ __ ] you guys are doing it
for free as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible